you look six months out
do you think they're do you think it's
going to be a bloodbath for democrats
right now if you're in the democratic
side you just you take your beating is
that a serious question yeah
bloodbath that's going to be a massacre
what are you talking about
yesterday we talked about california
she's not on the bus
she's not on the ballot well you know
here's the truth she'll be president
they're the leaders she will be yeah
okay greg said it i didn't say it greg
said it she'll be president then the
question presumes that maybe joe won't
be what are you talking about greg what
i'm saying is i'd be amazed if he's uh
running in 2024 and i'm no no we're
talking about before 22. oh no this will
be president okay good all right back to
what i was saying all right they're in
big trouble they're in big trouble
because of the border they're in big
trouble because of the economy they're
in big trouble because nobody likes them
because they lie and because they're
just stupid